okay let's go playing dragon I am dragon
let's stick with London stick with some
comfort zone
oh it's like chess but ping pong okay
and maybe that was a slightly confusing
quote okay III time yes so this is one
of the main positions ah
this move so I think Bishop e5 I've been
studying the sign so specifically my g5
could be a move I think just Bishop e3
of them I'm usually happy to open H file
black playing interestingly I'll play
Bishop b5 and maybe c4 ideas you can
take with Knight even takes with night I
should probably take with pawn I think
c4 makes sense when there's a pawn
enough 6a maybe castling also makes
sense a little bit conflicted there is
some issue with the server there is
flashing for a moment and Bishop e6 live
Queen e2 we need to Bishop f7 there's
about seven is coming
I'm just castle
had to mute them like they're the loud
sneeze okay let's move oh thank you I
feel blessed now I also feel allergic to
something oh my gosh
I thought allergy season has passed but
maybe not play this move see fine my
eyes are red maybe it's just like white
balance is off okay let's take so black
has a bishop hair
I mean box actually played interestingly
so far I do have to research this line
each five line always play Bishop f1
yeah tuck the bishop away begin the
hibernation
there's might be three in honor of
Knight be free there's also just a
smooth Oh II four is a major threat
though it's annoying I think I'll just
I'll play a 3d for at night h2 it's sad
but it's true oh I'm losing a pawn
though I'm losing a pawn that's not what
I wanted yeah more things which are sad
and true I can't even take on e4 because
takes defends a knight yeah the curse of
sneezing it's nothing to sneeze at like
what to do here I'm just so stuck I feel
so stuck
a few months ago I traveled I was in
Malaysia and I found myself in an
elevator there were like ten other
people in the elevator and it got stuck
on like the 40th floor some large
building and the people who I was who I
was stuck with like everyone was so loud
and complaining and scared for their
lives it feels like this position play
Brooks e3 I guess eventually we we
escaped like they had to call the
elevator rescue team and then we had to
take the stairs that's not a pleasant
experience oh this is also not a
pleasant experience what to do here
there will be something to learn from
this game for sure f3 unn Feingold is in
pain somewhere III Bishop here maybe
okay it's like and kind of breathe like
the elevator is still broke but no one's
dead yet this move are do Knight c3 you
have to defend my nights because bishop
tactics
[Music]
okay maybe 90 to 9f 1 like my pieces
actually kind of have squares each 5
looks really scary though
don't play h5 at some point in chief 3
g3 is actually kind of interesting like
92 9f 1 g3 still scared about h5
opponent taking a sweet time like so
much time really can take the rook
interesting I'm still like completely
stuck but trying to be alive have a 4
the problem is my knight Knight is
actually like the most stuck I have to
go for g3 at some point it's only way
maybe g3 we trade Knight g3 to e4 it's a
one hope and I'll Huff kingi to
supporting f3 it's a good move cling sad
I can't stack on g6 maybe King g2 first
I'm actually surprised like how alive I
am given the tragedy of the situation I
feel like I won't be alive for long play
this move there's too much tension had
to relieve the tension buck heating's
scary scary funds
now only still get the night TV for
probably not gonna happen
oh maybe it's happening takes takes its
way 94 first nice square you're cured
just want to win back the pond eight
seconds left it's incredible how alive I
am his d4 is gonna be week the night
actually like it does a great job like
defending all the dark squares defending
c5 coming off the Queen I'm really
working on the light squares here d4 is
gonna be week b7 will be a target
what is this check your tea for maybe
that's kind of scary
I'm Queenie six threats
I want to play rook t3 as well efficient
so I set up a trap Bishop e5 rook tasty
eggs it's nice I don't know what my
thread is though how could I take that I
can't take that and this move I'm just
slow still so scary
I feel like I'm coming back Queen b3
check ideas I know Queen eight shoes
come in check
this is terrifying
whoa it's might be free with a thousand
bits somehow I'm alive
things might be free whoa it's your
wizard Danny also a thousand bits
thanks a wizard to move a lot quicker
here I'm so scared ah position was good
too still playable
let's take you hmm
defending stuff want to plant the nine
on f6 bad decision really bad decision
still trying though
still trying mmm okay I got the night in
25 F for this move you even like that
five takes takes it's risky it's very
risky trying to attack
what's going on
Wow well the game how was ridiculous
gingham I felt like I was trapped in an
elevator and then I was gonna just get
rolled over and then something happened
and then more things happened and then
even more things happens I'm ADA not g7
Wow
tonight's the night so powerful that was
such a weird game you know man
I was getting smashed you look at that
position from earlier
holy moly guacamole with this position
it was so sad my pieces blocked pawn
that's why you never give up kids
click latch thanks for the thanks
everyone for the bits maybe I'll put
that on YouTube yeah you too people
never give up